obviously there's so much talent here
great coaches great players um it's just
bonding in the locker room and getting
to know one another and uh going out
there and like i said creating that
brotherhood and you know i know it's
already begun here and i'm a new player
here so i have to get to know everyone
but that's really it we want to
complicate football with x's and o's and
that is such an important
part of the game but the most important
part is the locker room and that
relationship thing and that's where my
focus has always been and always will be
nick foles looking sharp looking clean
with that first day of school haircut
introduced on his first day as a member
of the jacksonville jaguars four-year
deal worth 22 million
per year and he is very big on
relationships getting to know his
teammates and big cat last year in
jacksonville they did have some issues
from time to time i think the adversity
that they didn't expect to have
contributed to that sense from time to
time of dysfunction
is it too much to say that if you
establish the right relationships within
the locker room if everybody holds
together in the tough times that will
carry you to success
i i do think there's something to be
said for the personality of nick foles
and and you hear it i think there's no
coincidence that you had the same kind
of anonymous stuff come out about carson
wentz and that to me
put off a little red flag in my head
where i said maybe it's not carson wentz
maybe nick foles is such a dynamic
leader and you've never heard anyone
come out and say nick foles isn't a
great locker room guy so
it is a great move in that respect if
you're trying to repair you know what
what became a disastrous season for the
jacksonville jaguars last year the crazy
thing to me is
nick foles
in 2016 was ready to retire from the
national football league i mean that's
insane he went on to win a super bowl he
went on to to sign an 88 million dollar
deal it's incredible to think about how
this guy could have very easily walked
away and the ups and downs of his career
i mean i mentioned it earlier i can't
remember the exact numbers but the chip
kelly year when he was i think it was 27
touchdowns 27 and two yep 27 and 27 two
to almost being out of the nfl to
winning a super bowl for a city that had
never won a super bowl and was craved
craving that super bowl in philadelphia
where he will be a legend for life
to now signing an 88 million dollar
contract in jacksonville what a story
for the last few years with nick foles
he tied the single game record with
seven touchdown passes in 2013 against
the oakland raiders it prompted chip
kelly to declare that he would be the
eagles quarterback for the next thousand
years because that was a time when
jeff lurie the owner of the team had
just said we need to find a franchise
quarterback and then it wasn't long
after that they swapped him for sam
bradford and you know you you buried the
lead
on why nick foles almost quit football
it was his one year with your guy jeff
fisher that almost caused nick foles to
give up football forever i didn't bury
the lead i i actually left that out i
left those facts out
here's the only thing with all this said
about how crazy it's been a ride for
nick foles and the 88 million dollar
contract and the super bowl champion
super bowl mvp
i still am not 100 convinced that he is
i think he's a good quarterback i don't
he's not great in my mind and maybe this
is the recipe though because the jaguars
are in a win-now mode with the defense
they put together and the fact they were
one you know two years ago they were
some may say this is the best team in in
the nfl uh going into that you know game
against the patriots they almost won
they destroyed the steelers so i think
it's a good spot for nick foles if he
can be good will that be good enough
that's really the question for me for
nick foles in jacksonville
the the one thing that that we don't
know is is he kind of like a sneaky
natural leader is he not not not like
peyton manning or tom brady but but a
guy who just naturally will come in the
room and take it over not by being a
jerk but by being a nice guy and and
getting to know everybody and and you
know getting people over to his house
for dinner and spending time and and you
know maybe kind of breaking down some of
the rough edges that we've seen from
some of these guys like what if he can
get through to leonard fournette and get
fournette to fulfill his potential have
those conversations about man if you
just would really put the work in you
could be one of the all-time greats and
connect at that level and just push guys
buttons and get them to come together i
i think that uh special things could be
happening for nick foles especially
because folks like you think that they
won't have
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports